[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour cette
nouvelle semaine d'information locale
avec tv 78 nous sommes le lundi 12
novembre tout de suite les titres de ce
journal est la journée de mobilisation
dans l'éducation les syndicats appellent
aujourd'hui à débrayer contre les
suppressions de postes dans le
secondaire d actions partout dans le
département
colère aussi à maurepas où les
professeurs de ps manifestaient contre
la fin de l'option sport au lycée 17 m'a
invitée de cette édition delphine
remaniée secrétaire du snes fsu des
yvelines
les agents des lignes n ai eu eux seront
en grève ce jeudi un mouvement à l'appel
de la cgt cheminots de versailles motifs
notamment la fin de la vente des billets
grandes lignes dans les guichets un
rassemblement est prévu devant la garde
versailles chantiers
elle nous en parlons avec mathieu
bolle-reddat secrétaire général de la
cgt cheminots de trapped et puis retour
sur les commémorations du centenaire de
l'armistice à saint quentin en yvelines
dont montigny le bretonneux
la commune accueillait ce week-end la
flamme du souvenir celle de l'arc de
triomphe à paris
ce chiffre pour commencer 7000 le nombre
de places supplémentaires créés en
ile-de-france pour l'hébergement
d'urgence
ce plan a été annoncée ce matin par le
préfet de région michel cadot est
davantage de lits ouverts grâce aux
réquisitionnant de locaux d'anciennes
casernes lycée ou encore locaux
municipaux le dispositif des maraudes
sera également renforcée tout comme le
numéro d'urgence 115 que l'état souhaite
voir fonctionner 24 heures sur 24 et 7
jours sur 7 dans le cadre de la journée
de mobilisation nationale dans
l'éducation nationale une manifestation
s'est déroulée à maurepas
les professeurs de paix s du lycée 17
mars se sont rassemblées cet après midi
ils protestent contre la fin de l'option
sport prévue par la réforme du bac
reportage de manon barral dans
l'enseignement d'exploration eps en
seconde et son prolongement cycle de
terminale sont enseignées au lycée les
cette mare de maurepas à plus de 100
élèves chaque année mais les nouveaux
textes officiels des programmes du lycée
du bac font disparaître l'enseignement
conséquence les actuels élèves de
seconde ne pourront pas poursuivre
l'enseignement suivi cette année c'est
totalement méprisant pour les ans
niant puisqu'on nous impose maintenant
des programmes qui sont un faisable dans
les horaires impartis
avec des choix de programmes qui sont
fortement contestables les élèves ont
porté des tee shirts verts couleur de
l'espérance et se mobilisent pour garder
cet enseignement avec cinq heures en
second des quatre heures en première et
terminale
ça aurait pu permettre à plein de jeunes
de porc comme moi se défouler pour
comment pouvoir s'exprimer dans d'autres
matières que dans les matières où il
faut forcément à prendre des parents
sont venus soutenir les professeurs de
ps lors de cette manifestation
le sport pour moi c'est parti c'est une
grande conviction des choses très
importantes de la vie de de l'évolution
et ça serait vraiment dommage de
sacrifier cette spécialité qui en est
une actuellement cet enseignement est
implanté depuis presque vingt ans dans
l'établissement
les professeurs de ps espère interpeller
le ministre de l'éducation jean michel
blanquer air afin d'obtenir des moyens
pour recréer un enseignement optionnel
pourquoi dire qu'effectivement il faut
lutter contre l'obésité contre la
sédentarité et au final des actes qui
sont au contraire les professeurs
parents et élèves souhaitent que
l'ancien enseignements d'exploration et
de compléments implantés dans plus d'une
centaine d'établissements puissent se
transformer en enseignement de
spécialité afin de poursuivre le travail
engagé et pour parler plus largement de
cette journée de mobilisation dans
l'éducation nationale delphine rhmani
bonsoir relance mal vous êtes la
secrétaire générale du snes fsu des
yvelines c'est le premier syndicat des
enseignants du second degré en plateau
avec nous également mathieu bolle-reddat
bonsoir bonsoir on parle avec vous juste
après d'une autre mobilisation celle des
agents des lignes n ai eu ce jeudi vous
êtes le secrétaire général de la cgt
cheminots de versailles alors delphine
romagne ont commencé avec vous grande
journée de mobilisation donc aujourd'hui
dans l'éducation nationale
il ya eu également la vue cette
mobilisation des professeurs de psa
maurepas sur un sujet plus précis celui
de la fin de l'option eps ça traduit
quoi c'est un climat délétère
aujourd'hui chez les enseignants
oui tout à fait je crois que ça traduit
la colère des enseignants suite un
certain nombre d'annoncés et en
particulier la noce de la suppression de
2650 postes d'enseignants dans le second
degré
pour la prochaine rentrée c'est ça donc
environ 3000 postes qui ont été annoncés
çà c'est par jean-michel bancaire le
ministre de l'éducation nationale ce
budget de l'éducation nationale que vous
dénoncez les étudier par l'assemblée
nationale ce mardi demain et c'est une
première
aujourd'hui c'était l'ensemble des
syndicats de des enseignants qui se qui
se rassemblaient ça c'est une une force
pour faire peser dans la balance
oui alors tout à fait on a une
intersyndicale large c'est effectivement
de mémoire du jamais vu depuis une bonne
dizaine 2011 ouais voilà donc ça fait un
petit peu moins s'attend effectivement
je crois que c'est à la mesure de la
colère l'exaspération des enseignants
qui étaient dans la rue aujourd'hui
le ministère de l'éducation nationale
annonce et -2 14% de grévistes le snes
fsu lui table sur 50 % au niveau
national
forcément toujours une différence entre
les chiffres dans les yvelines est ce
que la grève a été suivie qu'est ce que
vous avez pu constater
oui alors la grève a été suivie donc au
niveau plus large de l'académie de
versailles
on est à une trentaine 2% de grévistes
avec des établissements qu'ils
localisent moment peuvent être très
mobilisés on avait 68% de grévistes au
collège philippe de champaigne humaines
de saint denis en plus de 50% au collège
des nénuphars de bréval
47 % presque 48 % au lycée jean monnet
de la curie green alors si on revient
justement sur les motifs de cette
mobilisation 3000 postes environ qui
seront supprimés quelle conséquence
concrète cela va avoir d'avoir ces
suppressions de postes alors les
suppressions de postes vont avoir une
conséquence directe évidemment sur les
conditions d'enseignement pour les
professeurs et d'études pour les élèves
donc c'est plus d'élèves par classe des
effectifs plus chargés donc moins de
temps points pour chaque élève
mais c'est aussi le résultat en
particulier de la réforme bancaire des
lycées qui va vers un appauvrissement de
l'offre éducative puisque tout
simplement nous n'aurons pas assez
d'heures pour offrir toutes les options
tous les enseignements facultatifs tous
les dédoublements qu'on pourrait
proposer aux élèves notamment une option
eps qui est supprimée au lycée ne mord
pas ça c'est aussi mobilisation qui a
été suivie pour pour le snes fsu
alors oui tout à fait donc si le
syndicat des professeurs d eps le snap
qui fait partie de la fsu qui étaient
mobilisés mais en fait la suppression de
l'option eps n'est qu'une des
conséquences assez vaste de la réforme
bancaire puisque c'est une conséquence
de la patrie semences de l'offre
d'options qui va être offerte aux élèves
et cette suppression de poste elle se
fait dans un processus où le nombre
d'élèves lui évolué c'est ça il ya plus
d'élèves mais il y aura moins de
professeurs voilà tout à fait on est sur
une augmentation constante des élèves
depuis une bonne dizaine d'années il ya
un léger tassement là mais ensuite il ya
les enfants du bas du mini baby boom de
2005 et 2006 qui vont peu à peu arriver
dans le second degré et donc on sait
qu'à partir de 2021 et
les effectifs vont repartir à deux plus
belles à la hausse et dans les yvelines
juste au monde et on est dans ce cas de
figure aussi oui tout à fait en montre
tout à fait dans le cadre qui est celui
du cadre national
alors pour expliquer cette situation
jean michel blanquer air de l'autre côté
annonce pour les primaires 1800 postes
qui vont être créés d'après donc le
ministre de l'éducation nationale pour
lui l'école primaire je le cite est la
mère de toutes les batailles
ce n'est pas là qu'il faut finalement
alloué les budgets en premier plan vers
la primaire c'est pas votre avis alors
tous que ce que nous contestons bien sûr
c'est très important la primaire et qui
font une à 10 - le problème c'est qu'on
fonctionne toujours un moyen constant et
que pour donner les moyens aux 1 il faut
en fait en prendra d'autres le
l'impact des mesures qui sont prises sur
le primaire ne se verront que dans
quelques années quand les élèves
arriveront dans le soulever et pour
l'instant ce sont les collégiens les
lycéens qui vont faire les frais de la
réduction de moyens dans le second degré
vous revenez de la mobilisation qui
s'est déroulé à paris un cortège qui a
défilé d'ailleurs est passé devant les
locaux du ministère de l'éducation
nationale comment s'est déroulée cette
manifestation
et bien c'est une manifestation qui
était assez assez étoffé il y avait
beaucoup de collègues dans la rue des
enseignants du second degré mais aussi
des professeurs des écoles
les collègues de lycées professionnels
aussi sont très en colère parce qu'on
parle beaucoup de la réforme blanquart
des lycées mais il ya aussi une réforme
de l'enseignement professionnel qui va
amener là aussi une diminution des
volumes d'enseignement général et des
suppressions postes et qui va aussi
avoir pour effet de séparer complètement
la voie technologique et générale d'une
part et la voie professionnelle d'autre
part est ce qui va obérer grandement les
chances des bacheliers professionnels de
pouvoir répondre aux attentes du
parcours super et ensuite pour
poursuivre avec succès des études dans
le supérieur
qu'est ce que vous demandez aujourd'hui
concrètement 4 qu'attendez-vous pardon
du ministère l'éducation nationale qu'il
recule sur sur ces annonces de
suppressions de postes tout à fait ce
que nous attendons c'est d'avoir des
moyens qui sont à la hauteur d'une
véritable démocratisation du système
éducatif c'est à dire offrir
suffisamment moyens pour offrir ce que
nous devons à tous les élèves y compris
les élèves en éducation prioritaire
puisque là aussi il faut souligner que
l'éducation prioritaire maintenant des
plus épargné que les effectifs
augmentent même en éducation prioritaire
donc nous demandons des moyens qui sont
à la hauteur des enjeux
un arrêt de la dégradation des
conditions de travail le hashtag pas de
vagues a fait beaucoup de bruit pour les
vacances de toussaint
mais l'analyse que nous portons aussi
c'est que c'est un phénomène qui en fait
qui est qu'ils aient un effet de la
dégradation des conditions de travail et
la difficulté que nous avons exercé dans
les établissements
dernière question que s'attendre à
d'autres mobilisations de votre part il
y en aura d'autres alors il y aura une
mobilisation fonction publique à la
rentrée des vacances de noël mois de
janvier où nous espérons que nous serons
avec nos caméras camarades cheminots que
nous soutenons
merci delphine roumanie d'avoir été avec
nous je rappelle que vous êtes la
secrétaire générale du snes fsu des
yvelines le syndicat d'enseignants du
second degré je me tourne vers mathieu
bolle-reddat qui est avec nous en
plateau je rappelle que vous êtes le
secrétaire général de la cgt cheminots
de versailles alors c'est une autre
mobilisation sociale un autre sujet les
agents des lignes n ai eu du transilien
se comptent en grève ce jeudi 7 à
l'appel de la cgt cheminots de
versailles alors vous rassemblerait
jeudi matin devant la gare de versailles
chantiers de versailles chantiers pardon
on aura l'occasion de représenter les
motifs dans un instant quel est le
climat actuel dans les trous les
chenilles non c'est qu'ils aient eu
cette mobilisation perlé avant l'été là
un autre combat pour vos cheminots
qu'elle est là le climat actuel dans
l'eau troupes ce ne sont pas mes troupes
en tout cas dans les cheminots eux mêmes
journaux dans les cheminots de
versailles en tout cas son nom
le l'état d'esprit aujourd'hui
effectivement combatif
nous avions annoncée pendant cette grève
cette grève qui a mis à jour les
questions de service public un service
public ferroviaire aujourd'hui nous
l'avions dénoncé cette loi c'est une loi
de casse du service public ferroviaire
c'est un plan social qui nous annonce
aujourd'hui le gouvernement après nous
avoir dit que avoir pu t nous avoir dit
sur tous les plateaux que suite à
l'adoption de cette loi le niveau de
service allait augmenter que les prix
allaient baisser que ça va être
formidable etc etc
eh bien ils commencent à présenter la
douloureuse partout il n'y a pas
aujourd'hui une région un département en
france où il n'y a pas au moins un
guichet qui ferme une gare qui ferment
au service commercial ou dans lequel il
y aura plus d'agent d'accueil qui
devient un point d'arrêt non gérer voire
une ligne carrément supprimés il y en a
aujourd'hui dans dans tous les
départements dans toutes les régions
tous les jours ces quotidiens vous avez
sur internet et vous voyez effectivement
ces annonces de trains supprimés
remplacés par des bus ou des ou de
guichet qui ferment donc aujourd'hui il
ya un plan social à l'échelle du pays
a la sncf qui a déclenché on ferme les
guichets pas partout en france ont fait
baisser le niveau de service aujourd'hui
est effectivement bien l'état d'esprit
des cheminots c'est de défendre leur
peau aujourd'hui de défendre leur peau
les fon leur emploi de défendre leurs
conditions de travail et aussi de
défendre le service public un service
ferroviaire au service du public au
service des usagers et donc qui s'est
complètement lié aujourd'hui à la lutte
contre les suppressions d'emplois
alors vous manifester jeudi il ya un
plan de suppressions qui est prévu de 35
postes la réduction vous le disiez de
l'amplitude horaire des gares l'arrêt
total également de vendre de billets
grandes lignes sur sur les gars au
guichet aussi vous étiez déjà mobilisés
en en septembre 150 personnes environ
qui s'étaient rassemblés déjà dans la
guerre des changes
la journée du 9 octobre a été une très
grosse journée sur notre périmètre à
versailles avait 150 manifestants qui
sont trouvés dans la gare de versailles
chantiers qui sont aller envahir les
locaux de la direction de la ligne n
justement pour dénoncer ce projet donc
vous l'avez rappelé dans les grandes
lignes mais je vous le dis très
rapidement ce projet donc à partir du
1er janvier prochain vise à supprimer 35
postes d'agents commerciaux et d'accueil
dans les gares des yvelines un peu des
hauts-de-seine mais aussi beaucoup des
yvelines cdc des gars qui vont être
désertifier alors oui le train va
s'arrêter quand on parle de fermeture de
gares au service commercial le train va
s'arrêter les gens vont remonter les
cendres mais ça va devenir ce qu'on
appelle un pang un point d'arrêt non
gérés c'est à dire que les soirs les
week-ends et parfois même tous les jours
de la semaine comme là je prends
l'exemple de la gare de ben qu'il sera
ouverte que le vendredi au service
commercial vous n'aurez plus de guichet
ou plus d'agent d'accueil ou d'escale
d'humanisation de sécurisation du site
et de la gare donc c'est une réduction
très importante du niveau de service
public pour pour les usagers des
yvelines
c'est aussi l'arrêt total de toute vente
grandes lignes c'est à dire de billet
grandes lignes dans tous les guichets
des yvelines et ça ya clairement une
déshumanisation alors il y aura plus de
dix ans pour appuyer sa drisse voilà au
défilé mais même si le guichet est
ouvert
vous ne pourrez plus acheter de billets
grandes vagues ans c'est à dire que dans
l'ensemble il faut que les gens s'en
rendent compte là dans l'ensemble du
département des yvelines
à partir du 1er janvier prochain il ne
sera plus possible d'acheter un billet
physique dans un guichet sncf sur
l'ensemble du département
c'est dans les gars vous allez pouvoir
acheter un froch un parfum un burger des
cigarettes mais publier les trains c'est
le chemin de fer de 21e siècle
concrètement et pourquoi vous mobilise à
nouveau ce jeudi vous n'avez pas été
entendu depuis depuis cette nation et
non on n'a pas été entendu on déplore
que des discussions même simplement
puisse s'ouvrir sur le sujet il ya
plusieurs élus qui se mobilisent aussi
des associations d'usagers des partis
politiques il aura notamment
l'association sos sujet a exagéré par
donc cette journée du 15 novembre 2 de
jeudi qui est la continuité du 9 octobre
cette fois n'est pas seulement appelé
par le syndicat elle est appelée par
notre syndicat cgt des cheminots
versailles le cgt des cheminots de
trappes aussi mais aussi par
l'association sos usagers qui est membre
de la fédération des usagers des
transports publics et des services
publics de monsieur de jean-claude
delarue c'est aussi appelé par le parti
communiste français
la france a soumises les jeunesses
communistes générations les jeunes
générations
le npa est la mobilisation autour de ce
sujet grosse mobilisation qui dépasse la
question des cheminots je pense que là
c'est aujourd'hui les usagers à qui on
présente la douloureuse aujourd'hui dans
le département sur le territoire qui
vraiment en ont marre on a on a diffusé
des tracts un peu partout dans les gares
qui était visé à fontenay à villepreux à
plaisir les clés à trappes et la
réaction des usagers est unanime
personne ne veut cette politique de
déshumanisation des gares et tout le
monde nous le dit ils payent leurs
impôts comme tout le monde ils payent
leurs
leur carte navigo comme tout le monde
c'est des usagers comme les autres ils
ont droit à un niveau de service public
qui est sensé de garantie par contrat
stif
je rappelle aujourd'hui et moi je le dis
et je lance un appel à madame pécresse
aujourd'hui qui est versailles est ce
qu'il annonce de la région ile-de-france
président de la région ile de france et
présidente aussi du coût du stif qui
s'appelle on2 france mobilisé mobilité
effectivement nouveau franc qui n'a pas
répondu à notre convoyer ce qu'on lui a
envoyé un courrier on a passé des appels
aussi pour essayer d'avoir un contact
avec madame pécresse elle est au courant
de ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
moi je lance un appel elle a signé un
contrat stif avec sncf un contrat qui
dans son article 23-3 suivez moi c'est
un peu technique mais au moins tout le
monde pourra le vérifier sur internet
dans son sang martin 23-3 dit que la
sncf garantie pour sur le contrat stif
sur l'ensemble de la période de garantie
le même nombre d'agencés dentaire dans
les gares et le même les mêmes horaires
d'ouverture des garde fous 1er janvier
donc voilà c'est c'est la patronne c'est
de l'argent public je le dis aussi en
tant que contribuable c'est de l'argent
public qu'on donne aujourd'hui à la sncf
pour garantir un niveau de service c'est
inadmissible qu aujourd'hui la direction
de la sncf pour faire des économies
parce que c'est juste ça c'est supprimer
des postes pour faire des économies
aujourd'hui ne garantissent plus haut
niveau de service qu'elle a signée par
contrat je rappelle puisqu'on arrive
déjà à la fin de cet entretien qu'il n'y
a pas de souci que votre rassemblement
est prévu donc ce jeudi dès 9 heures 30
devant la gare à des chantiers
maintenant merci mathieu baudry das
d'avoir été avec nous et je rappelle que
vous êtes le secrétaire général de la
cgt cheminots de versailles
ce dimanche nous commémorons le
centenaire de l'armistice signé le 11
novembre 1918 et mettre fin à la
première guerre mondiale toutes les
villes de saint quentin en yvelines
organiser leur cérémonie
elle nous étions attrapé à montigny le
bretonneux reportage de michael ni doro
et de marylène yapi chinois
m
[Musique]
montigny le bretonneux les
commémorations du 11-novembre commencé
dès le 10 au soir la ville faisait
partie des 35 communes de france à
accueillir la flamme du souvenir de
l'arc de triomphe
c'est émouvant et c'est ces
impressionnantes d'avoir la flamme
la flamme a fait un parcours dans toute
la ville entre les mains d'un jeune et
d'un aîné pour un devoir de mémoire
inter générationnelle moi j'ai emmené
j'emmenais mes fils à 2,6 et et novembre
pour qu elles pour qu'elles sachent
aussi ce qui s'est passé est plus
important que son enfant c'est bien
c'est bien il faut transmettre
il faut transmettre notre notre passé à
nos enfants pour qu'ils sachent pas ce
que c'est que l'histoire de france parce
que c'est une histoire qui nous qui nous
concerne tous donc c'est important je
crois que pour la ville de montigny
c'est quelque chose qui va rester
marquée dans les esprits de tous nos
habitants
d'ailleurs jacques abord rien que déjà
ce soir qu'on recommence combien ils
sont nombreux
il était tout aussi nombreux le
lendemain à braver la pluie pour la
cérémonie
la flamme est allumée face au monument
aux morts face à 250 enfants dont
certains ont pu lire des lettres de
poule et matt va retrouver trompés ils
devenus français jeanne a été gazé sur
le front et les morts d'épuisement dans
les années 1920 26 enfants ont également
déclamer les noms des 26 6 ni montant
tombé durant cette première guerre
mondiale
bravo à trappes aussi le partage entre
générations était de mise de nombreux
jeunes étaient présents et ont largement
participé à la cérémonie
c'est important oui surtout pour pour
tous celui qu'ils ont combattu
même pour nous un peu nos petits-enfants
savoir des commémorations pour se
souvenir qu'ils ont réuni les citoyens
de tous les monuments aux morts de froid
samedi environ 700 personnes se sont
rassemblées devant la mairie des longs
cours en mémoire de rachid ce père de
famille de 35 ans décédé la semaine
dernière des suites de ses blessures
il avait été frappé par cinq ou six
individus lundi dernier devant le lycée
17 mar à maurepas dans le cortège samedi
famille amis et habitants qui ont marché
silencieusement jusqu'au lieu de
l'agression
un appel au calme a été lancé pour
éviter toute vengeance une dispute sur
fond d'alcool aurait est déclenchée ce
lynchage la police judiciaire de
versailles en charge de l'enquêté
interpellé deux suspects jeudi et samedi
à la verrière et maurepas
samedi également la paix a été célébrée
à versailles plusieurs associations se
sont rassemblés devant le mur des
fédérés du camp militaire de satory un
lieu où des communards ont été fusillés
en 1871 miquel et demi d'euros et
mélanie poquet une paix sans conquête
voilà ce qu'il faut exiger 11 novembre à
11 heures les cloches ont sonné les 100
ans de l'armistice à versailles un peu
avant cinq associations célébrer la paix
la paix menacé tout le monde sent bien
que
non seulement au niveau mondial mais au
niveau européen disons que la guerre se
rapproche on va dire les choses comme ça
et que les conditions qui ont permis les
guerres dont nous avons parlé ce matin
la guerre de 14 ou la seconde guerre
mondiale se réunissent à nouveau et même
si ça prend des formes nouvelles
le lieu choisi le camp militaire de
versailles satory
des milliers de prisonniers y ont été
internés des communards ont été fusillés
en 1871
devant ce mur des fédérés sont des
hommes et des femmes qui se sont élevés
contre la guerre contre ces dictatures
militaires qui voulaient ce tour et je
mentais et donc on est dans la même
logique de guerre à la guerre nous avons
saisi l'occasion de l'armistice pour
effectivement commémorer cet événement
et faire un appel pour la paix nous
pensons que la guerre aucune guerre ni
inéluctable une bonne négociation doit
être réalisé à chaque fois qu'un conflit
se fait jour elle les associations se
rassembleront à nouveau l'année
prochaine sauf si leur espoir devienne
réalité
que la paix soit établie le lundi vous
en avez désormais l'habitude c'est la
chronique sport de michael et demi
d'euros bonsoir notre journaliste au
sport de cette rédaction on commence
michael cette chronique par du football
c'est ça avant de vous parler du match
de versailles contre les ulis en
nationale 3 je vous propose de revoir
cette action ont joué la deuxième
période de cette rencontre et c'est le
moment qu'a choisi un jour des ulis pour
commettre cette faute
regardez grégory les deux pieds sont
décollées c'est par derrière
le joueur sera évidemment expulsé est ce
qu'on appelle un attentat dans le jargon
on peut le dire on peut le dire je joue
l'autorisent en tout cas un rouge
logique on n'aime pas ce genre d'actions
on préfère voir le vrai football la
journée que michael est ce que cette
expulsion a eu des conséquences sur le
résultat et non cette expulsion n'aura
finalement pas avantagé à versailles
quatrième match nul de la saison ce
samedi 10 novembre les versets qui n'ont
pas réussi à forcer le verrou défensif
des ulis lors de cette 9e journée de
national 3 score final à 0 à 0 malgré
une nette domination des joueurs de la
cité royale on écoute les réactions hall
a bien maîtrisé le jeu on a eu beaucoup
d'action le problème c'est qu'on manque
d'efficacité c'est simple pour nous
nous sommes dans la maîtrise du jeu on a
été là on a la possession de balle les
actions c'est juste le sentiment d'avoir
fait le maximum pour pouvoir forcer la
décision en notre faveur mais mais il
nous a manqué un petit peu ce brin de
réussite ce dernier geste là qui nous
aurait permis de nourrir le score je
pense de tout gagner ce match s'il
attaque reste perfectible la défense de
versailles rassure l'équipe n'a encaissé
que cinq buts en huit matches disputés
cette saison une bonne défense qui
pourrait permettre à versailles de
passer au 8e tour de la coupe de france
les versets sont opposés ce dimanche 18
novembre
alès dragon un club polynésien au 7e
tour de la compétition
il y aura un certain à marama vahirua
sur la pelouse
il a 38 ans aujourd'hui les belles
heures de la d1 ce qu'on appelait à la
d1 à l'époque est aujourd'hui la ligue 1
ça ne nous rajeunit pas michael n'a pas
du tout alors également ce week-end du
rugby ah oui exactement de résultats
tout d'abord dans le championnat de
division honneur versailles et toujours
invaincus les joueurs de la cité royale
se sont imposés 23 à 3 sur le terrain du
clairement rugby club et réalise donc un
début de saison parfait avec cinq
victoires en cinq matches au classement
les versailles et compte maintenant 24
points et s'envole au classement
il compte cinq points d'avancé surmonter
son prochain match dimanche prochain sur
le terrain de la nuit en fédérale 2 l
équivalent de la 4e division nationale
plaisir a réalisé le gros coup du
week-end les plaisirs en battu ce
dimanche à l'extérieur charteau sixième
du classement
score final 19 à 17 une performance qui
permet aux yvelinois de remonter à la
10e place du classement avec 13 points
et de s'éloigner un peu de la zone de
relégation
prochain match dimanche prochain à
domicile contre l'équipe du rheu merci
michael plein d'autres résultats encore
dans votre 7,8 sport c'est à suivre
juste après ce journal avant quand même
pour terminer cette émission ce week-end
s'est déroulé est la sixième édition du
salon des vins des saveurs et des
couleurs à maurepas organisé par le
lion's club de maurepas s
saint-quentin-en-yvelines doyen ce salon
avait un but caritatif retour avec vous
ou michele demi d'euros et avec manon
varaldo
pour sa sixième édition le salon des
vins et des saveurs et des couleurs de
maurepas rassemble chaque année des
producteurs de toute la france et de la
région
nous sommes une des plus anciennes
cultures de france donc nous produisons
en fait sur place différents sons sortes
de produits surtout à base de truites
l'association lions club maurepas 50 ans
divine doyen a toujours le même objectif
reverser les profits du salon à une
action caritative
ça dépend des années bien sûr mais on
arrive à sortir à peu près on va dire
entre 7000 et 8000 euros et qui nous
permettent de d'avoir des actions
intéressantes et importantes dans
l'année 62 exposants ont fait le
déplacement pour ce salon des vins des
saveurs et des couleurs
je trouve ça bien de pouvoir montrer son
travail tout en pouvant participer
à une action caritative créateur de
lampes de mosaïque de bijoux c'est aussi
l'occasion de trouver des idées cadeaux
à l'approché des fêtes de fin d'année je
crée des petits objets donc des petites
pochettes tous hors de mon atelier qui
est chez moi tout est fait intégralement
par mes soins
je crée des boucles d'oreilles également
pour oreilles percées et non percée
puisque il n'ya pas me le demande dans
les yvelines
durant tout le week-end les exposants
ont accueilli les visiteurs
ce salon s'inscrit dans la vie locale
j'essaie de venir tous les ans parce que
je trouve que les gens qui viennent
exposer coiffer des bons produits des
artisans pour la plupart je trouve que
c'est important d'aller faire ses
courses dans les grandes surfaces et
j'espère qu'il va continuer longtemps d
un événement à retrouver tous les 2e
week-end de novembre à maurepas
c'est la fin du set 8 journal belle
soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]